GOOD EVENING, EVERYONE.
LET ME START WITH A FEW WORDS
ABOUT THE RECENT ELECTIONS HELD
IN THE UNITED STATES.
WHAT WE SAW WAS THE STRENGTH AND
RESILIENCE OF THE AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY AND WE SAW IT IN
ACTION AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
PROVED ONCE AGAIN THAT DEMOCRACY
IS WHO WE ARE.
THERE WAS A STRONG REJECTION OF
ELECTION DENIERS AT EVERY LEVEL
FROM THOSE SEEKING TO LEAD OUR
STATES AND THOSE SEEKING TO
SERVE IN CONGRESS, AND ALSO
THOSE SEEK TO GO OVERSEE THE
ELECTIONS.
THERE WAS A STRONG REJECTION OF
POLITICAL VIOLENCE AND VOTER
INTIMIDATION.
THERE WAS AN EMPHATIC STATEMENT
THAT IN AMERICA THE WILL OF THE
PEOPLE PREVAILS.
I HAVE TRAVELED THIS WEEK AND
IT'S BEEN CLEAR JUST HOW CLOSELY
THE WORLD AND OUR ALLIES AND OUR
COMPETITORS AS WELL HAVE BEEN
FOLLOWING OUR ELECTIONS AT HOME.
EXCUSE ME, I HAVE A LITTLE COLD.
AND WHAT THESE ELECTIONS SHOWED
IS THAT THERE'S A DEEP AND
UNWAVERING COMMITMENT IN AMERICA
TO PRESERVING AND PROTECTING AND
DEFENDING DEMOCRACY.
NOW, LET ME SPEAK BRIEFLY ABOUT
OUR AGENDA OVER THE PAST FEW
DAYS.
IN EGYPT AND IN CAMBODIA AND
HERE IN INDONESIA.
IN THIS MOMENT OF GREAT GLOBAL
CHALLENGES FROM GLOBAL INFLATION
TO THE CLIMATE CRISIS TO
RUSSIA'S BRUTAL WAR AGAINST
UKRAINE, WE'RE BRINGING TOGETHER
THE BROADEST POSSIBLE COALITION
OF PARTNERS TO DELIVER RESULTS.
AT COP27 IN EGYPT I MADE IT
CLEAR THAT THANKS TO THE BOLD
AGENDA OF OUR ADMINISTRATION, WE
PURSUED FROM DAY ONE TO TACKLE
THE CLIMATE CRISIS AND ADVANTAGE
ENERGY AND SECURITY AROUND THE
WORLD WE WILL MEET OUR EMISSIONS
TARGETS UNDER THE PARIS
AGREEMENT.
WE WILL KEEP WORKING WITH OUR
PARTNERS TO SUPPORT THE MOST
VULNERABLE COUNTRIES IN BUILDING
RESILIENCE TO CLIMATE IMPACTS
AND TO ALIGNING GLOBAL A.M.
MISSION WHILE SUPER CHARGING OUR
CLEAN ENERGY EMISSIONS.
AT THE SUMMIT I LAID OUT A
COMMITMENT TO WORKING WITH OUR
PARTNERS THE INDO-PACIFIC TO
ENSURE A FUTURE THAT IS VITAL TO
THIS REGION, THAT'S FREE AND
OPEN AND PROSPEROUS, AS WELL AS
SECURE.
AND I MET WITH OUR ALLIES FROM
AUSTRALIA, JAPAN AND THE
REPUBLIC OF KOREA UNDERSCORING
OUR COMMITMENT AND DEEPENING OUR
ENGAGEMENT WITH OUR CLOSEST
PARTNERS AND STRENGTHENING AND
COOPERATION AMONG OUR ALLIES TO
MEET SHARED THREATS TO OUR OWN
SECURITY AND TO THEIR SECURITY,
INCLUDING THE DPRK.
AND LET ME MEET -- I JUST MET
IN-PERSON WITH XI JINPING OF THE
PEOPLE'S REPUBLIC OF CHINA.
WE HAD -- EXCUSE ME -- WE HAD AN
OPEN AND CANDID CONVERSATION
ABOUT OUR INTENTIONS AND ABOUT
OUR PRIORITIES.
IT WAS CLEAR -- HE WAS CLEAR AND
I WAS CLEAR THAT WE WILL DEFEND
AMERICAN INTEREST AND VALUES,
PROMOTE UNIVERSAL HUMAN RIGHTS
AND STAND UP FOR THE
INTERNATIONAL ORDER AND WORK IN
LOCKSTEP WITH OUR ALLIES AND
PARTNERS.
WE'RE GOING TO COMPETE
VIGOROUSLY BUT I'M NOT LOOKING
FOR CONFLICT, I'M LOOK TO GO
MANAGE THIS COMPETITION
RESPONSIBLY.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE -- MAKE SURE
THAT EVERY COUNTRY ABIDES BY THE
INTERNATIONAL RULES OF THE ROAD.
WE DISCUSSED THAT.
THE ONE CHINA POLICY -- OUR ONE
CHINA POLICY HAS NOT CHANGED.
HAS NOT CHANGED.
WE OPPOSE UNILATERAL CHANGE IN
THE STATUS QUO BY EITHER SIDE
AND WE ARE COMMITTED TO
MAINTAINING THE PEACE AND
STABILITY IN THE TAIWAN STRAITS.
IT WAS ALSO CLEAR THAT CHINA AND
THE UNITED STATES SHOULD BE ABLE
TO WORK TOGETHER WHERE WE CAN TO
SOLVE GLOBAL CHALLENGES AND
REQUIRE EVERY NATION TO DO ITS
PART.
WE DISCUSSED RUSSIA'S AGGRESSION
AGAINST UKRAINE, REAFFIRMED HOW
ARE SHARED BELIEF IN THE THREAT
FOR THE USE OF NUCLEAR WEAPONS
IS TOTALLY UNACCEPTABLE AND I
ASKED THAT SECRETARY BLINKEN
TRAVEL TO CHINA TO FOLLOW UP ON
OUR DISCUSSIONS AND CONTINUE
KEEPING THE LINES OF
COMMUNICATION OPEN BETWEEN OUR
TWO COUNTRIES.
LOOKING AHEAD AT THE G20
MEETINGS TOMORROW WE WILL BE
TAKING ON THE VERY ISSUES THAT
MATTER TO THE PEOPLE'S LIVES NOT
ONLY HERE, BUT ALSO -- ALSO OUR
ALLIES AND OUR PARTNERS.
THAT MEANS TACKLING THE
SUFFERING THAT RUSSIA AGGRESSION
HAS UNLEASHED NOT JUST IN
UKRAINE PEOPLE, BUT PEOPLE
AROUND THE WORLD, PARTICULARLY
FOOD INSECURITY AND
STRENGTHENING THE FUNDAMENTALS
OF OUR GLOBAL ECONOMY FOR
EVERYONE.
SUPPORT FOR DEBT RELIEF, REFORMS
FOR MULTILATERAL DEVELOPMENT
BANKS, INVESTMENTS TO BOLSTER
GLOBAL HEALTH SECURITY AND TO
MAKE SURE THE WORLD IS BETTER
PREPARED FOR THE NEXT PANDEMIC.
THE G20 HAS BEEN AN IMPORTANT
FORUM FOR THE WORLD'S LARGEST
ECONOMIES TO WORK TOGETHER FOR
THE GOOD OF PEOPLE EVERYWHERE
AND I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO OUR
MEETINGS TOMORROW.
LET ME CLOSE WITH THIS, ON MY
FIRST TRIP OVERSEAS LAST YEAR I
SAID THAT AMERICA WAS BACK.
BACK AT HOME, BACK AT THE TABLE
AND BACK TO LEADING THE WORLD.
IN THE YEAR AND A HALF THAT'S
FOLLOWED WE'VE SHOWN EXACTLY
WHAT THAT MEANS.
AMERICA IS KEEPING ITS
COMMITMENTS, AMERICA IS
INVESTING IN OUR STRENGTH AT
HOME, AMERICA IS WORKING
ALONGSIDE OUR ALLIES AND
PARTNERS TO DELIVER REAL
MEANINGFUL PROGRESS AROUND THE
WORLD.
AT THIS CRITICAL MOMENT NO
NATION IS BETTER POSITIONED TO
HELP BUILD THE FUTURE WE WANT
THAN THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
NOW, I'M HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS
AND I'M TOLD THERE ARE GOING TO
BE FOUR QUESTION NURSE, BUT I'M
NOT GOING TO DO TEN QUESTIONS
FROM EACH QUESTIONER.
ALL RIGHT?
LET'S MAKE THAT CLEAR AT THE
OUTSET HERE.
SO KEN THOMAS, "WALL STREET
JOURNAL."
>> Reporter: -- MEETING THAT YOU
DID NOT WANT -- DID NOT WANT
COMPETITION TO TURN INTO
CONFLICT.
BASED ON THIS MEETING TODAY, DO
YOU BELIEVE A NEW COLD WAR WITH
CHINA CAN BE AVOIDED?
AND SPECIFICALLY ON THE ISSUE OF
TAIWAN, YOU SPOKE ABOUT
INTENTIONS.
DO YOU BELIEVE CHINA IS
PREPARING, INTENDING TO INVADE
TAIWAN AT SOME POINT?
AND WHAT WARNINGS DID YOU ISSUE
TO PRESIDENT XI IF HE WERE TO
TAKE SUCH ACTION?
>> WELL, TO ANSWER THE FIRST
PART OF YOUR QUESTION, I
ABSOLUTELY BELIEVE THERE NEED
NOT BE A NEW COLD WAR.
I'VE MET MANY TIMES WITH XI
JINPING AND WE'VE BEEN CANDID
AND CLEAR WITH ONE ANOTHER
ACROSS THE BOARD.
I DO NOT THINK THERE IS ANY
IMMINENT ATTEMPT ON THE PART OF
CHINA TO INVADE TAIWAN AND I
MADE IT CLEAR THAT OUR POLICY IN
TAIWAN HAS NOT CHANGED AT ALL.
IT'S THE SAME EXACT POSITION
WE'VE HAD.
I MADE IT CLEAR THAT WE WANT TO
SEE CROSS STRAIT ISSUES
PEACEFULLY RESOLVED SO IT NEVER
HAS TO COME TO THAT.
I'M CONVINCED THAT -- THAT HE
UNDERSTOOD EXACTLY WHAT I WAS
SAYING, I UNDERSTOOD WHAT HE WAS
SAYING AND, LOOK, I THINK THE
UNITED STATES IS BETTER PREPARED
THAN ANY COUNTRY IN THE WORLD
ECONOMICALLY AND POLITICALLY TO
DEAL WITH CHANGING CIRCUMSTANCES
AROUND THE WORLD AND I THINK
THAT -- I THINK XI JINPING IS --
WE AGREED THAT WE WOULD SET UP A
SET OF CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE ON
ISSUES THAT WERE -- THAT WE HAD
TO FURTHER RESOLVE DETAILS WE
AGREED THAT WE WOULD HAVE OUR
CHIEF OF STAFF -- OUR -- THE
APPROPRIATE CABINET MEMBERS AND
OTHERS SIT AND MEET WITH ONE
ANOTHER TO DISCUSS THE DETAILS
OF ANY -- EVERY ISSUE THAT WE --
THAT WAS RAISED AND WE RAISED A
LOT OF ISSUES.
SUNG KIM, ASSOCIATED PRESS.
>> Reporter: MR. PRESIDENT, YOU
MET WITH PRESIDENT XI AND YOU
MET WITH HIM FACE-TO-FACE AFTER
HE HAD UNQUESTIONABLY
CONSOLIDATED HIS POWER AT HOME.
SO NOW THAT YOU'VE MET WITH HIM
FACE-TO-FACE, HOW DO YOU ASSESS
HIS SORT OF POSTURE TOWARDS THE
UNITED STATES NOW, AND DID YOU
FIND HIM PERSONALLY TO BE MORE
CONFRONTATIONAL OR MORE
CONCILIATORY AND WILLING TO
COMPROMISE?
>> NEITHER AND YES.
YES, I DIDN'T FIND HIM MORE
CONFRONTATIONAL OR MORE
CONCILIATORY, I FOUND HIM THE
WAY HE'S ALWAYS BEEN, DIRECT AND
STRAIGHTFORWARD.
AND DO I THINK HE'S WILLING TO
COMPROMISE ON VARIOUS ISSUES?
YES.
I THINK HE UNDERSTANDS THAT --
LOOK, I THINK -- HOW CAN I SAY
THIS TACTFULLY?
I THINK THE -- I THINK THE
ELECTION HELD IN THE UNITED
STATES WAS STILL LEAVES A LITTLE
BIT UNCERTAIN WAS SENT A VERY
STRONG MESSAGE AROUND THE WORLD
THAT THE UNITED STATES IS READY
TO PLAY.
THE UNITED STATES IS -- THE
REPUBLICANS WHO SURVIVED ALONG
WITH THE DEMOCRATS ARE OF THE
VIEW THAT WE'RE GOING TO STAY
FULLY ENGAGED IN THE WORLD AND
THAT WE, IN FACT, KNOW WHAT
WE'RE ABOUT.
AND SO I DON'T GET ANY SENSE
THAT THERE'S MORE OR LESS
CONFRONTATION.
WE WERE VERY BLUNT WITH ONE
ANOTHER ABOUT PLACES WHERE WE
DISAGREED OR WHERE WE WERE
UNCERTAIN OF EACH OTHER'S
POSITION AND WE AGREED WE WOULD
SET UP, AND WE DID, MECHANISMS
WHEREBY WE WOULD MEET IN DETAIL
WITH OUR -- THE KEY PEOPLE IN
EACH OF OUR ADMINISTRATIONS TO
DISCUSS HOW WE COULD RESOLVE
THEM, OR HOW -- IF THEY WEREN'T
RESOLVED, ON WHAT BASIS WERE
THEY NOT RESOLVED.
SEBASTIAN SMITH, THE AFP.
>> Reporter: THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT.
EXCUSE ME, I DON'T USUALLY TALK
THAT LOUD.
DOES THE RETAKING OF KHERSON IN
UKRAINE SIGNAL A TURNING POINT
IN THE WAR IN YOUR OPINION THAT
THE UKRAINIANS -- WHERE THE
UKRAINIANS COULD REALISTICALLY
PURSUE THEIR ULTIMATE GOAL OF
EXPELLING THE RUSSIANS
COMPLETELY, INCLUDING RETAKING
CRIMEA?
IF SO, DOES THE U.S. INTEND TO
SUPPORT AND FACILITATE THAT GOAL
AS YOU'VE BEEN DOING SO FAR WITH
THEIR OTHER GOALS, OR WOULD YOU
PERHAPS SEE KHERSON AS A
DIFFERENT KIND OF INFLECTION
POINT, BASICALLY A GOOD TIME TO
START NEGOTIATING NOW THAT
THEY'VE GOT SOME MORE STRENGTH
THAN THEY HAD A FEW WEEKS AGO?
>> FIRST OF ALL, IT WAS A
SIGNIFICANT, SIGNIFICANT VICTORY
FOR UKRAINE.
SIGNIFICANT VICTORY.
I CAN DO NOTHING BUT APPLAUD THE
COURAGE, DETERMINATION AND
CAPACITY OF THE UKRAINIAN PEOPLE
AND THE UKRAINIAN MILITARY.
I MEAN, THEY HAVE REALLY BEEN
AMAZING.
I THINK IT'S HARD TO TELL AT
THIS POINT EXACTLY WHAT IT MEANS
IN TERMS OF -- BUT I'VE BEEN
VERY CLEAR THAT WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE A CAPABILITY
FOR THE UKRAINIAN PEOPLE TO
DEFEND THEMSELVES AND WE ARE NOT
GOING TO ENGAGE IN ANY
NEGOTIATION, THERE'S NO --
NOTHING ABOUT UKRAINE WITHOUT
UKRAINE.
IT'S A DECISION UKRAINE HAS TO
MAKE.
I THINK YOU'RE GOING TO SEE
THINGS SLOW DOWN A BIT BECAUSE
OF THE WINTER MONTHS AND THE
INABILITY TO MOVE AS EASILY
AROUND THE COUNTRY, BUT I THINK
IT REMAINS TO BE SEEN EXACTLY
WHAT THE OUTCOME WILL BE EXCEPT
THAT I'M CONFIDENT THAT RUSSIA
WILL NOT OCCUPY OR DEFEND
UKRAINE AS THEY INTENDED FROM
THE BEGINNING.
I HAVE TROUBLE READING THIS.
REUTERS, NATANIA BOSE.
>> Reporter: QUICK QUESTION ON
NORTH KOREA WHICH APPEARS POISED
TO CONDUCT A NEW NUCLEAR TEST.
I'M WONDERING IF YOU CAN TALK
ABOUT YOUR SPECIFIC DISCUSSIONS
WITH PRESIDENT XI ON THAT.
TO WHAT EXTENT DO YOU THINK
CHINA HAS THE ABILITY TO TALK
NORTH KOREA OUT OF CONDUCTING
SUCH TESTS AND WHAT ARE THE
REPERCUSSIONS FOR U.S./CHINESE
RELATIONS IF A TEST GOES
FORWARD?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, IT'S
DIFFICULT TO SAY THAT I AM
CERTAIN THAT CHINA CAN CONTROL
NORTH KOREA, NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO, I MADE IT CLEAR TO
PRESIDENT XI JINPING THAT I
THOUGHT THEY HAD AN OBLIGATION
TO ATTEMPT TO MAKE IT CLEAR TO
NORTH KOREA THAT THEY SHOULD NOT
ENGAGE IN LONG RANGE NUCLEAR
TESTS AND I MADE IT CLEAR AS
WELL THAT IF THEY DID, THEY
MEANING NORTH KOREA, THAT WE
WOULD HAVE TO TAKE CERTAIN
ACTIONS THAT WOULD BE MORE
DEFENSIVE ON OUR BEHALF AND IT
WOULD NOT BE DIRECTED AGAINST
NORTH KOREA -- EXCUSE ME, IT
CHINA BUT IT WOULD BE TO SEND A
CLEAR MESSAGE TO NORTH KOREA.
WE ARE GOING TO DEFEND OUR
ALLIES AS WELL AS AMERICAN SOIL
AND AMERICAN CAPACITY AND SO --
BUT I DO NOT THINK THAT -- IT'S
DIFFICULT TO DETERMINE WHETHER
OR NOT CHINA HAS THE CAPACITY.
I'M CONFIDENT CHINA IS NOT
LOOKING FOR NORTH KOREA TO
ENGAGE IN FURTHER ESCALATORY
MEANS BECAUSE I MADE IT CLEAR --
AND I MADE IT CLEAR FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING AND LAST YEAR AS
WELL THAT WE WILL DO WHAT IT
NEEDS TO DEFEND OUR CAPACITY, TO
DEFEND OURSELVES AND OUR ALLIES,
SOUTH KOREA AS WELL AS JAPAN,
AND THAT IT WOULD BE -- WE WOULD
BE MORE UP IN THE FACE OF CHINA,
BUT IT WOULDN'T BE BECAUSE OF
CHINA, IT WOULD BE BECAUSE OF
WHAT WAS GOING ON IN NORTH
KOREA.
AND, AGAIN, ON A NUMBER OF THESE
ISSUES, WE HAVE PUT TOGETHER
TEAMS WITH OUR NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISER, SECRETARY OF DEFENSE
AND OTHERS ARE GOING TO BE
ENGAGING WITH THEIR COUNTERPARTS
IN CHINA TO SEE -- WE ARE NOT
GOING TO BE ABLE TO WORK
EVERYTHING OUT, I'M NOT
SUGGESTING THIS IS KUMBAYA, YOU
KNOW, EVERYBODY IS GOING TO GO
AWAY WITH EVERYTHING IN
AGREEMENT, BUT I DO NOT BELIEVE
THERE'S A NEED FOR CONCERN AS
ONE OF YOU RAISED A LEGITIMATE
QUESTION, A NEW COLD WAR.
I THINK THAT -- I WILL CONCLUDE
BY SAYING IT THIS WAY, I WANT TO
BE CLEAR AND BE CLEAR WITH ALL
LEADERS, BUT PARTICULARLY WITH
XI JINPING, THAT I MEAN WHAT I
SAY AND I SAY WHAT I MEAN.
SO THERE'S NO MISUNDERSTANDING.
THAT'S THE BIGGEST CONCERN IS --
I HAVE IS THE MISUNDERSTANDING
ABOUT INTENTIONS OR ACTIONS ON
EACH OF OUR PARTS.
SO WE WENT INTO -- I LOOK AT MY
TEAM, HOW LONG DID THAT MEETING
LAST?
THREE AND A HALF HOURS.
SO WE COVERED AN AWFUL LOT OF
TERRITORY AND I MUST SAY THAT HE
WAS AS STRAIGHTFORWARD AS HE HAS
BEEN WITH ME IN THE PAST AND I
THINK THAT WE UNDERSTAND ONE
ANOTHER, WHICH IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING THAT CAN BE
DONE.
I GUESS ALL OF YOU ARE GOING
SWIM FROM HERE, IT'S NOT FAR.
>> Reporter: MR. PRESIDENT, WHAT
SHOULD AMERICA EXPECT FROM
CONGRESS AS IT RELATES TO
ABORTION RIGHTS?
>> I DON'T THINK THEY CAN EXPECT
MUCH OF ANYTHING OTHER THAN
WE'RE GOING TO MAINTAIN OUR
POSITIONS.
I'M NOT GOING TO GET ANY MORE
QUESTIONS, I SHOULDN'T EVEN HAVE
ANSWERED YOUR QUESTION.
[ INAUDIBLE QUESTION ]
>> I DON'T THINK THERE'S ENOUGH
VOTES TO CODIFY UNLESS SOMETHING
HAPPENS UNUSUAL IN THE HOUSE.
I THINK WE'RE GOING TO GET VERY
CLOSE IN THE HOUSE BUT I
DON'T -- I THINK IT'S GOING TO
BE VERY CLOSE, BUT I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO MAKE IT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU, EVERYBODY.
THANK YOU.